Okay.
Well,
in 1921,
a group of workman working in the
highway near the village of St Joseph,
which is here in Essex and east Anglia,
um,
discovered a skeleton.
Uh,
the first day it's all stayed
uncovered a modern crime,
but it was soon established
that it was very old.
And subsequently on the basis of both
documentary evidence and forensic
evidence,
they identified it as being probably
the remains of a woman named Ursula Kemp
who had been executed at St Seth and
buried in the highway rather than in
consecrated ground in the year 1582
and Ursula camps crime was the alleged
causing of death by witchcraft.
Now,
today,
obviously I'm going to talk
about witchcraft and perhaps
explain how it was that
people like Ursula camp
came to such an end.
First of all,
we need to start with a little context
by discussing the larger place of not
simply witchcraft,
a specific crime,
but magic,
uh,
within the popular culture
of early mornings island.
We could perhaps define that world of
magic as being essentially a body of
beliefs,
a large body of beliefs and practices
regarding supernatural power,
which stood outside the world of form of
religion and yet well widely known and
helped people to cope with their
anxieties and their insecurities.
It helped them to cope above all because
it involved various ritual means of
manipulating supernatural powers,
so as to ward off misfortune
or else to alleviate it.
This world of magic then
was was essentially a world
of trying to propitiate or
to manipulate unidentified supernatural
powers largely for the purposes of
protection and relief.
It wasn't,
and it's important to stress this,
it wasn't an alternative religion.
It was a whole mess of
supplementary beliefs and
practices been described by one
historian as the debris of many
different systems of thought.
It was regarded with some
suspicion by the church,
but it was not regarded
as a threat as such,
at least not initially.
One historian writing about popular
beliefs has put it splendidly.
I'm quoting from him names
James Are Belka beach.
It was a large loose,
pluralistic affair without
any clear unifying principle.
It encompassed superhuman
beings and forces,
witches and wise men and a mass of
low grade magical and superstitious
practices.
The whole was less than
the sum of its parts.
the sum of its parts for,
it was not a cosmos to be
contemplated or worshiped,
but a treasury of separate and specific
resources to be used or applied in
concrete situations that
puts it extremely well.
These means of tapping
into supernatural par.
We're very widely known,
you could say they were part of the law
which was acquired by every child as
part of their education for life,
like learning to cross
the road as it were,
but the world of magic also had its
specialists and they were those who were
known as the cunning folk,
cunning men or wise women.
These individuals were those who were
known to have special knowledge over and
above the average knowledge of magical
practices and who are often believed to
have a special inherent power
often inherited.
It was thought to pass in the blood.
The coming folk who were pretty numerous.
One survey of known cutting folk in East
Anglia suggest that there was a known
cunning man or a wise woman,
uh,
within 10 miles of any village.
These people were appeal to vote
for a variety of specific purposes.
Um,
the first place they often will
appeal to for medical reasons.
Very often they had specialist
knowledge of Herb's,
which they would administer often
accompanied by spells to increase their
effectiveness.
The psychological effect of
the incantation going along
with what may well have
been the practical effect of the Herb's.
They used Ursula Sheila Kemp for example.
It was such a person,
she was known as a healer in her village.
She was good at curing arthritis.
Apparently
again,
they would appeal to for
the diagnosis of witchcraft.
If a person suspected that
they might've been bewitched,
they might go to the cunning folk
for the provision of counter magic.
They might help the victim to identify
who might have attacked them in this
awkward manner and
advise on counteraction.
Uh,
one of my favorite cutting men,
uh,
came from a town in the north of England,
stokes Lee and he was
called John Wrightson.
Uh,
and he was known as old rights and the
wise man of stoke sleep and people went
to him for help with their horses.
He was a horse leach.
He was very good at telling whether your
horse had been bewitched and knowing
how to take the appropriate
counter measures.
People went to the cunning folk also for
the recovery of lost or stolen goods.
And they went for advice and the telling
of fortunes and to this extent the wise
women and the cunning men were the popular
equivalent of the astrologers who had
a more elite clientele in this period.
So the cutting folk provided a variety
of real services and the best of them may
well have been quite skilled
therapists in their way.
One historian of medical practice in
this period says we ought to count them
amongst the medical practitioners
of the time they were cheap.
They were available and in
many ways quite knowledgeable.
However,
the church was pretty unhappy
about this kind of activity.
It didn't like popular magic.
The official teaching of the church
was that if a person suffered any
misfortune,
it must be the result
of divine providence.
It was either a test of your
faith or on the other hand,
it was a judgement on your sin.
The only proper response to his fortune
was to search one's own heart for the
possible causes of such
divine intervention to pray,
to repent,
to trust.
In God's providential purposes,
the church rejected
magical means of relief.
It accepted the possibility,
but it rejected the means.
God could not be commanded
by spells and incantations.
Therefore,
if there was any supernatural
response to such practices,
it must be from evil spirits.
And so given these beliefs,
we find the deeply pious of the period
searching their hearts for the sins which
had brought misfortune upon them and
sometimes finding quite extraordinary
answers.
You find it in their diaries.
For example,
for example,
the,
the diary of the Reverend Ralph Joslin,
a minister in the late 17th century
who were having lost a dearly loved
daughter,
searched his heart as to why
God should have done this,
why he should've taken her away and came
to the conclusion that it was because
he had neglected his clerical duties
because of his enthusiasm for playing
chess.
He had played chess too much.
God had taken his daughter.
That's the conclusion he came
to and he gave up playing chess.
This is a 17th century God,
not a nice modern user friendly God.
Little wonder then if these were the
official teachings of the church that the
greater part of the population preferred
to explain their misfortunes in terms
of just bad luck or their
neglect of protective magic
or perhaps the malevolence
of evil spirits and malicious neighbors.
Well,
this world of popular magic had long
existed and it was long to enjoy.
You can find much of it's still alive
and well deep into the 19th century
and it endured because in
various ways it helped,
but the problem of witchcraft
is altogether more distinctive.
That involved a specific kind of magic,
the causing of injury or death by
the malevolent and malicious use of
supernatural powers against
another or their property.
And that was the practice
which was known as Malefic Iom.
That's the Latin legal term which was
used for this [inaudible] magic and
concern with witchcraft in this way
had a quite distinct chronology.
The possibility of malevolent magic
had always been there of course,
but concern with it was undoubtedly at
an unusual height in the late 16th and
earlier 17th centuries.
And the key to why that was so is perhaps
to be found in what the historian of
the Spanish inquisition,
Henry Cayman has described as a peculiarly
horrible conjunction in European
history.
I conjunction,
he says,
between popular superstition on the one
hand and ecclesiastical fantasy on the
other,
the fantasies of churchmen,
the popular superstitious element
doesn't need any further elaboration.
Of course,
it had always been the case that some
individuals were regarded as having this
special access to occult power,
the element of ecclesiastical fantasy.
However,
that was something that was
peculiar to western Christendom.
You don't find it in
the orthodox tradition,
and it was peculiar to the early modern
period emerging at the end of this 15th
century and growing in strength in the
16th essentially it involved the belief
that all witchcraft in fact
involved worship of the devil.
And as a result,
the elaboration of a stereotype
of the witch which portrayed,
which is not merely as
dabblers in magic or perpetrators
of mollifies against neighbors,
but as something much more
serious members of an organized,
diabolical and malevolent cult,
not just village wise
women or cutting men,
but enemies of God
throughout continental Europe
and indeed in Scotland.
Also,
the result of these beliefs was that the
main driving force behind the spasmodic
witch hunts,
which can be found in the period was
probably religious zeal and the great with
chance,
which would be found
scattered across Europe,
died back only when the judges came to
doubt the reality of that stereotype of
the witch and came to doubt the notion
that witchcraft was an organized cult
threatening to Christian society,
one of the first legal
jurisdictions to make that decision.
That whole thing was
just a terrible error,
was in fact the Spanish inquisition when
doesn't usually associate the Spanish
inquisition with progressive movements.
But in 16,
10,
they were the first to abandoned,
to refuse to deal with cases of this kind.
Uh,
the French parliament,
uh,
again did so in 1640 some years later,
so it gradually died away.
But throughout both Catholic
and Protestant Europe,
for some time,
there was a unity in the war
against which is as enemies of God.
Well,
how far was that pattern true of England?
The usual answer is that
it wasn't true of England.
And that was for several reasons.
First of all,
the authorities in England never
actually embraced the full ecclesiastical
stereotype of witchcraft as
evidence of a diet of membership,
of a diabolical cult.
Continental European ideas
about the nature of witchcraft
was certainly known in
England.
Books from Europe were
read by the educated,
and these ideas were disseminated
by a number of English writers,
usually clergyman,
uh,
particularly from the
1580s or thereabouts.
Gradually such notions did seep into
popular beliefs and you begin to find them
at the popular level.
By the mid to late 17th century.
But nevertheless,
that notion of the nature of witchcraft
didn't have much influence on English
law,
which was never prosecuted
as a heresy in England.
The first act which was passed against
sit in 1542 made it a felony or any crime
that was a felony,
carried the death penalty,
made it a felony to practice
witchcraft for unlawful purposes,
but that act was only on the statute
book for five years and it was repealed.
After that there was actually
no law against witchcraft,
but nearly 20 years.
Then in 1563 there was a new act.
It was made a felony to
invoke evil spirits and to um,
if they were invoked to
cause the death of another,
then execution was the
punishment otherwise,
which is where to be imprisoned or put
in the pillory and face death only for a
second offense.
Then finally in 1,604 came a third act.
It elaborated on the 1563 act.
It made it a felony to be which anyone
too other than death or their injury
for lesser forms of sorcery,
people faced imprisonment and
death for a second defense,
but some elements of
continental European ideas.
We're beginning to creep in
at last into this third act.
For example,
it was made a felony to dig up dead
bodies for the purposes of practicing
witchcraft,
exactly why they were concerned with that.
They don't explain,
but that was one of
the clauses of the act.
It was also made a felony to consult
with or to feed an evil spirit for any
purpose.
So some elements of the notion of
dye diabolical pact and the like.
We're beginning to creep in,
but not all of the kind of
stereotype of witchcraft,
which was well known north of the border
in Scotland or in continental Europe.
Witchcraft remains seen as
not specifically diabolical,
but rather as Keith Thomas
puts it and antisocial crime,
very unusual one,
but an antisocial crime rather than a
form of heresy and that characteristic
that it's treated as a specific kind of
crime comes out in the trial evidence.
For example in English witchcraft trials,
it's very rare to find any reference to
making packs with the devil you get the
odd one in the 17th century,
but there few so no diabolical packs
really know which is sabots at which which
is met and fisted danced
with the devil and so forth.
Very little sex with devils in English,
witchcraft trials.
So that was a prominent
feature in continental trials.
English,
which is didn't fly.
They didn't have much
fun at all really um,
English which has,
did however have pets.
They had imps and familiars
as they were known,
usually small animals and they seem to
have been part of popular beliefs in
England,
which would have a familiar,
which could act on her behalf.
They'll steal a camp,
for example,
was alleged to have had four familiars,
two cats,
a toad,
which was called pigging and the lamb,
which was called Tiffin.
What the English trials focused on first
and foremost was simple [inaudible]
acts.
Other elements usually entered only in
a handful of notorious cause celebs,
which is we're always
condemned for malefic IA
and they were hanged rather than burn.
It was a crime,
not a heresy.
Secondly,
particular witchcraft prosecutions were
rarely instigated from above in England.
That's another important difference.
There is no evidence that the
authorities actually wanted a witch hunt.
One outstanding exception
to this generalization was
the activities in 1645 to
47 of a witch finder
called Matthew Hopkins,
who operated in East Anglia and
to all intents and purposes,
hired himself out as a consultant
for the discovery of witches.
That was an organized witch hunt from
which Matthew Hopkins personally profit.
But it's the only really outstanding
example of such an outbreak in the history
of witchcraft in England.
It's made the subject of a
wonderful Vincent Price movie,
uh,
30 years or so ago,
which find a general,
which I do recommend.
It got nothing to do with the history,
but it's a great movie.
Okay,
so which craft prosecutions in
England tended not to come in?
These witch hunts would,
would bring hundreds of cases.
They didn't come in great waves with
the major exception of Matthew Hopkins's
activities.
They were sporadic.
They were occasional,
they came up one or two
at a time and so forth.
In addition,
in English law,
torture was not used except in state
certain state trials when it was specially
authorized by the Privy Council
in day to day trials taught,
he was not used.
Whereas it was routinely used in many
jurisdictions in continental Europe and
indeed in Scotland.
As a result,
people were not tortured into confessing.
large numbers of people were
not implicated by people
under torture who named
names.
What you get in the witchcraft statistics
from the English courts is really a
lot of individual prosecutions brought
from below by the alleged victims of
witchcraft seeking redress in the
courts just like any other crime.
So there are some important differences
in the way all of this was handled in
the law.
Nevertheless,
England did share in the General European
preoccupation with witchcraft even
though to a lesser extent
just how far it shed is not fully known.
That's because the relevant legal records
don't survive for every area of the
country.
They survive pretty fully,
but the whole of the southeast
and for the county of Cheshire,
but for other parts of the country,
they tend to survive only
from the 17th century.
A point which is relatively late
in the history of this crime,
but where we do have the evidence,
one of the striking features is that the
trials appear to have been relatively
rare except for the home circuit,
the counties around London.
If you look at the a handout,
if you look at the two graphs,
graph a gives you the trials which
took place in different sized circuits
and the line at the top showing
the real spike is the home circuit.
You can see how there are vastly more
cases being heard in the whole home
circuit than in any other jurisdiction
for which we have the records.
The second spike is Matthew Hopkins
operating in 16 five but the first spike,
as you'll see it was in the later years
of Elizabeth and even within the home
circuit,
this area,
the cases came predominantly
from one part of it,
the county of Essex to the east of London.
If you look at the second graph graph,
be there,
you have the different counties of the
home circuit broken down and it's clear
enough that Essex is
absolutely outstanding in
terms of the numbers of cases
which came from that county.
To give you some actual figures in
the whole of the reign of Elizabeth,
the county of Hartfordshire,
which is just to the north of London,
quite a populous county produced
only 24 witchcraft cases.
The county of Sussex,
large county to the south of London
produced only 14 the county of Essex
produced 172 in fact between 50 and 60
and 1680 270 individuals were prosecuted
for witchcraft in Essex.
Whereas in comparison,
taking a county of similar
size and similar population
in the period between 50
and 80 and 1,709 only 34 were prosecuted
in the county of Cheshire for which we
have good evidence.
So Cheshire 34 Essex 270
in general.
Most of the trials for which we have
evidence took place in the last quarter of
the 16th century in the home
circuit and in Essex in particular,
they were at their peak between the
1570s and the early 1590s looking at the
country as a whole,
trials become very rare everywhere.
After about 16 to 20 the numbers are
falling away after about 1620 with again,
the notable exception of the activities
of Matthew Hopkins in the mid to late
1640s which caused a new peak of
concern within a downward trend.
Well,
that downward trend,
the decline of witchcraft cases after
around 1620 is something which historians
have found relatively easy to explain.
The decline can be
explained in number of ways.
First of all,
from at least the 1580s
some of the justices of the
peace and the assize judges
who had to handle these cases were
very worried about the difficulties of
proving witchcraft.
They weren't necessarily skeptical.
They frequently believe that
witchcraft was possible,
but how could you prove in law that
a particular individual was actually
responsible unless they confessed?
How could you prove that something was
caused by witchcraft rather than by
natural causes?
If,
for example,
someone died of a lingering illness
and even if it was witchcraft,
who did it,
so they were worried about the problem
of proof and they talked about it.
In witchcraft cases,
normal rules of evidence could
not apply and this bothered them.
Increasingly in the 17th century,
lawyers who were worried about all of
this became very unwilling to entertain
cases.
They tried to talk people
into not prosecuting or they
or they or they insisted
upon additional evidence if
a case was to go forward.
In addition from the early
17th century onwards,
there seems to have been an actual decline
amongst educated people in belief in
the very possibility of witchcraft.
The conviction grew that it was a fantasy
which had been projected onto wretched
people by hysterical neighbors.
The conviction grew that the accused did
not have the occultic powers that were
claimed,
even if they thought they
did so they were frauds.
And in the later 17th century there
was the growth of awareness of the
mechanical philosophy of psoriasis.
Newton who regarded the university as
having been created by God and subjected
to laws which were immutable.
You could not tamper with God's natural
doors through using spells and the like.
Well all of this probably had its
influence in the course of the decline of
witchcraft prosecutions though initially
it's most likely that it was the legal
concern,
the young willingness of some lawyers
and judges to handle these cases,
which was the main cause of the falling
off noticeable by the early 17th
century.
So in these various ways,
one can perhaps satisfactorily explain
the decline of concern with witchcraft,
but we still have to explain the
16th century rise of concern.
And that turns out to
be much more difficult,
much more difficult because this seems
to have been genuine popular concern with
cases coming up from below.
One calm,
simply explain it in terms
of the activities of a
number of bishops are judges
the dominant explanation.
It was put forward some years ago by
Keith Thomas and Alan Mcfarlane and two of
the pioneering works on this subject and
they explained the rise of witchcraft
prosecutions in terms of a detailed
examination of the circumstances of
surviving cases,
which is we're usually women and
they were frequently elderly women,
which is where usually accused
of bewitching neighbors
within their own village,
not strangers or was
neighbors people they knew,
which is often poorer
than the alleged victims.
This suggested that the accusations were
therefore arising from tensions between
relatively marginal women in the village
community and better off neighbors who
might be men or women.
Then they looked at the known
circumstances of cases and the classic
circumstances were more
or less as follows.
A quarrel would occur between
neighbors ending in one of them,
the supposed which going away,
cursing or muttering.
The victim would then suffer
some form of personal misfortune.
The victim would then begin to entertain
suspicion that they'd been bewitched.
They would talk to other neighbors,
some of who might have similar suspicions
about the person they suspected.
A person would then be identified as a
possible which as a malevolent person in
the eyes of the village,
it's possible that some of those who were
so accused did practice magic and did
believe themselves to
have the power to harm.
And to some extent they may even have
used it as a form of begging with menace.
The corals between neighbors,
which initiated cases very often began
when someone was turned away having been
begging or asking for
a favor of some kind.
It's possible that some of these marginal
women responded to being gradually
identified as witches by playing the part,
by scaring their neighbors as it were,
into meeting their needs.
That could go on for years and often did,
but eventually some incident serious
enough to trigger off an actual court
prosecution would occur,
perhaps a death,
something of unusual seriousness.
When that happened,
someone would bring an accusation,
other neighbors would chime in.
There were lots of such accusations.
Um,
Alan McFarland founded in Essex.
There were,
there was an average of four
accusers for each accused week,
so other people would chime
in with their suspicions.
Supplementary proofs might be looked for.
For example,
the witches mark existence on the witches
body of a award or mo or other mark,
which seem to be insensitive to pain
and which was thought to be the place at
which the witches familiar
would feed on her blood.
If they found such a thing,
it was considered additional proof
and the which might be found guilty
fine.
Well,
those do indeed seem to have been
what one can think of as the classic
circumstances though there were,
they were by no means unusual.
Witchcraft accusations could
arise in other contexts.
They could arise,
for example,
as a result of personal rivalries in local
politics and accusation of witchcraft
was something which was easy to throw
at another person in order to discredit
them.
So there are other circumstances.
Not all witches were women,
some were men though most
of the women and so on.
But these do appear to have
been the classic circumstances.
Why then should the late 16th and early
17th centuries have seen a peak of such
accusations because surely one could
find such circumstances earlier and one
could find them later.
Why was that the peak period of anxiety,
Thomason Mcfarland suggest first of all,
it was partly because of the loss of
the protective magic which had been
supplied by the medieval church.
The Church of England allowed the
belief in witchcraft to continue,
but it wouldn't offer ecclesiastical
means of counter magic and it forbade
people to resort to them.
If that was the case,
then bringing a legal accusation,
a trial,
and eventually seeking an execution
would be the only way out of the impasse.
A second part of the explanation is that
the reason for so many late 16th and
early 17th century trials was that
because that period was one of unusual
tensions within village
society within neighborhoods,
it was a period,
as we know of economic distress,
one which saw a declining
position for the poor,
especially perhaps the
elderly and marginal poured,
the widowed and so forth.
The poor laws had not yet been fully put
into effect to provide for such people,
neighbors who themselves were feeling
the pinch might be less willing to show
charity,
less willing to help.
They might feel uncomfortable about that.
They might feel rather guilty about that.
That's my prey on their minds and
make them sensitive to misfortunes,
which they saw as the revenge of people
to whom they had refused charity.
People who had perhaps custom
accusing such a person of witchcraft was
a way of severing their responsibility.
Assuaging their feeling of guilt,
transferring it to the accused,
which
well,
all of this is an ingenious explanation,
which may well hold a great deal of truth
and it's indeed widely accepted as an
account of a sociology and
psychology of accusations.
Recently,
that explanation of Thomas and Macfarlane
has been elaborated by more focus upon
the fact that most of those accused
of witchcraft would of course,
women.
The tensions within neighborhoods seem
to have come to focus upon punitive
action against women.
Above all,
why was that?
Thomas and Mcfarland suggest that it was
simply a product of the fact that most
of the economically marginal and most
of the agent in particular were indeed
poor women.
Some feminists.
Writers see it as more sinister as
constituting an attack upon women who buy
their social situation,
or perhaps they're aggressive
personalities stood outside
the normal controls of
the patriarchal household.
It's an important issue,
but one has to pause.
I think before jumping to the conclusion
that witch hunting was in effect a form
of repression of women.
Certainly it was the case that the
Association of witchcraft with women's
specifically,
which was universal derived in large
part from fundamentally misogynistic
attitudes,
women were seen as being morally weaker,
as more prone to temptation as more
likely to use account means to revenge
themselves upon their neighbors
spells where the weapons of the weak.
However,
witchcraft prosecutions,
we're not simply a patriarchal drive
against marginal aggressive or troublesome
women.
The magistrates who
heard the cases were men,
but the accusers themselves
were very often other women.
The work of James Sharp reveals how
many of the suspicions that led to
accusations actually arose in the
female's spheres of village life.
They will often initiated by other women.
Women themselves felt threatened by
witchcraft and would deeply involved in
identifying and accusing witches.
And on the other hand,
many of the juries,
universally male who heard these cases,
failed to believe them.
Many accused witches were
acquitted by male juries.
The gender element then is clearly there,
but it's complex.
It's paradoxical.
These issues remain far from resolved.
Um,
but they add further complexity.
Do any discussion of the sociology
of witchcraft accusation.
There are a number of other problems also,
um,
to which I need to draw your attention.
Problems relating not so much to
the sociology of specific witchcraft
accusations,
but to the history of
witchcraft as a crime.
Um,
two questions in particular
arise in the English case.
First of all,
why would the witchcraft statutes
passed in the first place?
And secondly,
once they were past,
why did such an utterly disproportionate
number of the cases arise in the county
of Essex?
Essex seems to be wholly
unusual so far as one can tell.
If there were neighborhood tensions
which were acute in the county of Essex
leading to such accusations,
why were there not such neighborhood
tensions in the counties of Kent or Sussex
or Hartfordshire,
all of which were places which had a great
deal in common with Essex in terms of
social structure and local
economy and so forth.
Why Essex?
Well,
some brief suggestions.
First of all,
as regardless of the laws,
I think it's worth considering that
these laws were passed when they were
perhaps because of a
convergence of two things.
First of all,
both of the major witchcraft statutes in
England were passed at the beginning of
new regimes.
One in Elizabeth second parliament,
one in the first parliament of King James,
the sixth and first.
It makes one wonder whether there
was an element in this legislation of
symbolism that acts on this subject.
We're past perhaps as part of the
propaganda of a new regime that passing
statutes of this nature in a sense
conferred legitimacy on new regimes by
showing their firms stance against a
particularly symbolically charged form of
deviants to be opposed to witchcraft was
in a sense a declaration of legitimacy.
The acts may have had then a certain
symbolic function when they were passed
through parliament without
opposition so far as we can tell.
Secondly,
another element of the timing of the act
is the fact that there may have been an
element of political
contingency specifically in
the form of suspected threats
to the person of demonic in 1561 two
years before the 1563 act was brought
forward.
A plot had been discovered in which
sorcery was allegedly being used against
Elizabeth Williams.
Sessile was horrified to find when
the plot was uncovered that there was
actually nothing under
statute book forbidding it.
This may have been a contingent political
reason for moving ahead with the
witchcraft statute.
It may have persuaded him to go along
with one or two of the bishops who were
themselves interested in having
legislation on this issue.
That's an interpretation then which
might be particularly relevant to the
passage of the 1563 act.
Though the full details of its passage
through parliament remain unknown,
the documentation is too poor.
The act of 1,604 is a
lot clearer following the
acception of James the Sixth of
Scotland as James the first of England.
He was a man with a profound
interest in witchcraft.
He'd a book about it and
the subject in school.
He'd written a book about the subject in
Scotland following his act session and
the Union of Crowns.
The witchcraft statutes of both England
and Scotland were overhauled and revised
by a committee of judges and bishops.
This again may have been a symbolic act.
They decided to do it.
Then why?
Then it's a new regime and a
new act was passed in Scotland.
At the same time,
it may have been helped along again
by the fact that in 1,604 there was a
particularly notorious,
which could have case in London itself,
which may have drawn attention
to the problem once again.
So what I'm suggesting is that these
acts of parliament were essentially
introduced as legitimizing symbols,
good and godly laws introduced
by good and godly regimes.
Yet there's no evidence that
the authorities that put
them on the statute book
actually wanted a witch hunt.
If they'd wanted one,
they could have had one,
but they didn't.
What they did was to make witchcraft
prosecutions possible in the royal courts.
And to that extent,
the political and ecclesiastical elite
had a bigger role in making possible the,
the,
the prosecutions,
which took place then is often recognized.
So one can perhaps explain why the actual
put on the statute book and that kind
of way,
but that still leaves
the problem of Essex.
Why Essex?
Is it possible that Essex as a local
society was peculiarly conscious of the
threat of witchcraft?
But why should that be so it's quite
clear that people might feel threatened by
malefic IOM in any part of England.
Why should they act against it so
much more in the county of Essex
and the only suggestion I can make on
that issue is that the use of the criminal
law against which is had had
terrible publicity in Essex.
Essex was unusual in the sense that
it's sore three cause celebs three group
trials.
They took place in 1566 only three
years after the passage of Elizabeth's
statute in 1582 and in 1589 in each of
these cases and initial accusation was
vigorously pursued by local justices
of the peace who happened to have a
particular personal
concern about witchcraft.
That meant that instead of just
one person going on trials,
small groups of women went on trial and
these trials were well publicized in
pamphlets which were written about
them and which survive to this day.
You can read them on early
English books online.
All of this then may have given peculiar
publicity to witchcraft as a threat and
what could be done about it when one does.
Then whether a number of particularly
scandalous local cases occurring in this
county had the effect of heightening
anxiety about witchcraft within Essex,
enhancing the sense of threat,
which people felt making it
more intense than elsewhere.
And of course providing an object
lesson in how to deal with it.
So are we dealing then with a moral panic
breaking out within a particular local
society,
which subsequently died down in the
17th century until it was artificially
revived again by the
activities of Matthew Hopkins,
to which find a general in 1645
yeah.
Well,
Sheila camp incidentally was one of
the women tried in one of those group
trials,
the one of 1582
so to conclude the whole issue
of the history of witchcraft,
why people were so concerned with it at
a particular point in time is clearly,
enormously complex.
But what I'm suggesting is that first,
the case of England was different to a
degree from what was going on elsewhere
in Europe at the time.
There were no mass witch hunts to marry
popular superstition and ecclesiastical
fantasy and the way one found in
various parts of Europe and in Scotland,
Matthew Hopkins,
excepted.
Secondly in England,
which craft prosecutions did come up
spontaneously from below and they probably
usually arose in pretty much the way
Thomas and Macfarlane and James Sharp have
suggested as far as individual
cases were concerned,
though it was an accusation which could
also be used for malicious prosecution
and was so used.
But thirdly,
these cases could only arise because of
the existence of laws which were perhaps
essentially symbolic and
contingent in their origins
and their once those laws existed.
Fourthly,
the cases arose only sporadically.
The sense we have of a
definite chronological pattern
in witchcraft prosecutions
is very heavily influenced,
as you've seen by the case of Essex alone.
Essex does seem to have been
unique for very special reasons,
which we may never be able
to do more than to guess that
elsewhere in the country
cases a row sporadically,
occasionally,
no clear pattern beyond the fact that
they were more common in the late 16th
century than later.
And finally there was no English witch
hunt because at the end of the day,
the authorities in both church
and state didn't want one.
They never felt sufficiently threatened
to instigate one against those.
They deemed the enemies.
The potential for a witch hunt was there
and it long continued village tensions
hadn't faded.
The difference of the 17th century from
the latest 16th century was above all
that the judicial authorities not
only failed to seek a witch hunt,
but actually became active in suppressing
the accusations which were brought
before them.
So then I suspect that overall both
the rise and the fall of witchcraft
prosecution is best explained by the
way in which the law first of all gave
people and then later took away from them
the opportunity to settle a particular
kind of personal conflict through the
use of the law and the prosecution of
people to their deaths.
The beliefs behind all of that,
we're very ancient and the long continued,
but the history of witchcraft is very
much to do with the use of the criminal
law in the way I've described.
The crucial issue was perhaps
that for a short while,
for two generations,
there was indeed a conjunction
of longstanding patterns
of popular belief with a
shorter term enhancement of the anxieties
and the credulousness of the elite.
It was they who passed the laws that
made witchcraft trials possible.
They later repented of their folly.
They avoided the
enforcement of those laws,
and eventually in 1736 they repealed them.
But that of course was about
150 years too late for us.
Hula Kemp.